hi everyone and welcome to this
interactive full course session by
simply learn on computer networks
in this course we will look into various
aspects of computer networks
that is a computer network is an
interconnected system
of devices to transmit data and
information and to share multiple
hardware and software resources
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to remiss an update
from us
now without further ado let's take a
look at the agenda for today's session
in this course to begin with we will
understand what is ethernet which forms
the basis of connection medium in a
computer network
moving on we will look into difference
between a switch hub and a router which
are the most three important networking
devices moving on we will look into
network topology
next
we will look into information regarding
tcp and ip model
continuing with osi model
the dhcp explained
distance vector routing protocol which
helps in transfer of information and
data over the network channel
then we will look into what is an ip
address which is used to transmit data
over the network channel
moving on we will look into difference
between ipv4 addresses and ipv6
addresses
and at the end we will look into circuit
switching and packet
switching
with this we have completed all the
basic parts of a computer network
moving on we will look into more complex
headings
which are
what are subnetting subnetting is a part
of computer network which prevent the
wastage of ip address in a network
moving on we will look into multiple
networking commands which are helpful in
troubleshooting network issues
next we will look into the user datagram
protocol
also known as udp
moving on with stop and wait protocol
which forms the basis of transfer of
information and data in a network
channel
using the application of stop and rate
protocol we have sliding window protocol
and go back in our queue protocol
as for the last heading for this full
course we have top 10 networking
interview questions which will prepare
you for any networking related interview
move on to the first heading
what is ethernet
ethernet is a form of communication
network that uses a wired medium to
connect devices for data exchange in a
network
for example lan
also known as local area network
also van known as wide area network
ethernet also applies different protocol
on the data to be transmitted over the
communication channel efficiently and
smoothly
moving on let's look into why to use
ethernet
as we now know the ethernet is a mode of
connection for multiple devices to share
and exchange data
but using this way of transmission also
has its benefit
for example
the ethernet network provides us with a
high speed connection for sharing data
ethernet also provides the user data
with a secure channel for transmission
the data that is transmitted over the
ethernet channel is reliable and has
really faced any issues at the sender
side
let's move on to the next heading
now we will look into different types of
ethernet
in general the ethernet is divided into
three different types
first is
the fast ethernet
this type of ethernet operates on a
twisted pair cable
with a data transmission speed of up to
100 mbps per second
fast ethernet connections are used for
personal connections
or use in companies that require low
internet connection
moving on we have gigabit ethernet
this connection is used for high speed
internet connection
with a speed ranging from 1000 mpps to
1gbps
it is an upgraded form of fast ethernet
and the last type is
switched ethernet
this ethernet type installs network
devices such as switches or hubs so as
to improve the network transmission
the transmission range for switched
ethernet connection is around 1000 mbps
to 10 gbps
now let's look into the working of
ethernet
ethernet services specifically work in
the first layer of the osi model that is
known as the physical layer and the
second layer of usm model
also known as data link layer
functioning of the ethernet can be
divided into three different parts
first step being
acquiring the physical address that is
mac address media access control address
of the sender and the receiver device
then the second step is to check the
data security
quality of the data and the connection
speed of the transmission channel for
efficient and smooth transmission of
data over the network
and the last step is to check network
traffic and detect any error that occurs
in the communication channel
to solve these issues if occur
csma protocols and other protocols are
used
for example the csma protocol is used in
case of packet collision in the network
channel
now let's look at a simple ethernet
model for further clarification of the
steps
but before we begin with the model
the point to be noted is
the transmission of data over the
ethernet channel is divided into two
parts
frames and packets
where packets represents a unit of data
in the network
whereas frame refers to a collection of
data packets being transmitted over the
channel
and the application of ethernet services
which includes security traffic check
and protocols being applied on the data
and that is when it reaches the receiver
end
moving on let's look into advantages and
disadvantages of using ethernet
for advantages we have
cost of installing ethernet connection
is low in comparison to other network
channels
the security of the data being
transmitted
over the ethernet channel is maintained
as for disadvantages we have
it is suitable only for establishing
short distance communication network
due to high requirement of hardware
resources
whereas ethernet is also not suitable
for sharing real-time data and
information
let's look into some more advantages and
disadvantages
ethernet is suitable for maintaining the
data quality of the information being
transmitted
it also provides high speed
data transmission option for the network
for disadvantages we have
the network traffic issue is a drawback
of installing ethernet cables
troubleshooting faults and issues in the
internet cable is also a troublesome
work
now let's move on to the last heading
for this topic that is
ethernet versus internet
the first difference is connection
medium
for ethernet connection physical
cables are required that means it uses
wired medium for connection
whereas in case of internet it uses
wireless mediums such as satellites
as a connection medium
moving on the next difference is
network model
the ethernet is available only for a
low distance connection for example lan
whereas internet is available for all
the network connection distances
beat lan
man
or van
let's move on to the next difference
that is
network control
for ethernet
the complexity of the connection medium
is low due to the less distance it uses
and also provides
much efficient transmission of data over
the communication channel
whereas for internet is a large
collection of networks and hence require
large group of administrator for control
the last difference between ethernet and
internet is
network security and reliability
ethernet connection is a secure network
from external interference
and provides data security
whereas in case of internet it is an
open type of connection so it is more
prone to hacking attempts and less
secure network
let's begin with the introduction to the
network hub
a network hub is a device that is
designed to connect multiple
network units in a closely connected
network channel
so hubs are also used in lan networks
the network hub shares data with the
destination device by acting as a
central connection point of data
transmission and connecting all the
other devices in the channel
some points to remember about the
working of a hub hub is incapable of
processing any complex protocols due to
the absence of an intelligent unit in
the system
also the physical model of the hub is
composed of multiple sockets for
connecting network devices
now let's move on to the working of a
network hub
for the first scenario we will assume
that a message is being sent through the
hub to a destination node
let's begin
according to the example
hub has received a message for device a
where it will share the same message to
device a
which is a basic protocol
but due to the absence of any
intelligent unit or a processing point
in the hub device it will share a
message for a to all the other connected
devices
that are device p as well as device c
this creates a lot of access of traffic
in the network channel
now let's move on to the second scenario
which is when receiving a response from
the device
in this case when the device shares a
response to the hub to be sent to the
sender device
it will share
the same response to all the other
connected devices again due to the same
reason that is lack of any processing
unit or intelligent point
in the network channel
please take a look at the arrow points
which is very important during the
transmission of data
with this we have clear all the points
that are important for a network hub now
let's move on to the next topic that is
information on switches
the network switch is a networking
device that is active in the data link
layer
of the usa model and is designed
specifically to connect private networks
in a lan channel
switches are programmed to share
messages only with our designated device
that is mentioned in the header format
of the message
which cuts down the network traffic in
the channel
switches uses different types of data
which can be either packets or data
frames
switch uses a destination source address
and the destination address
for forwarding the message to the
specific device in the system
now let's look into the working of a
network switch
the first scenario is when the message
is received to a switch and is to be
forwarded to a particular device
in this case we are receiving a message
for device a
which will be shared only to device a
according to the address mentioned in
the header format
this
decreases the network traffic in the
channel and also prevent
the access of message to device b and
device c
this task of managing the address and
sending the data to the designated
device is handled using mac address
which is used by the network card
installed in the network device
now let's move on to the second scenario
that is receiving a response from the
device
in this case the switch will receive a
response from device a
which will be forwarded to the sender's
address mentioned in the message
and this will prevent the response to be
shared to device b and device c due to
the presence of a processing unit in the
switch
with this we have completed all the
important points
to be known regarding a network switch
now let's move on to the third topic
that is information on routers
let's begin
a network router is a device that is
designed to share data between multiple
networks at a much larger scale in
comparison to a hub or a network switch
it is connected to multiple devices at a
very large level that can be considered
as
metropolitan area network or a wide area
network
router uses ip addresses to share data
with the specified device in the network
channel
and they also perform the task of
translating
an address that is available in a
private network to a globally recognized
network
so that it can access internet
which is known as
nat
network address translation
if you want to look further in the
translation process that the router
performs you can visit our video on the
same
in the simply learn channel
now with this we have completed all the
introduction points regarding a network
router now let's move on to the working
of a network router
in this scenario a message has been
received by the router for device a
from which it will reduce the ip address
for the device a and share the data
the message deliver efficiency is
highest in case of a network router
as it uses routing path from a routing
table to guide the message to its
destination point
and vice versa
with this we have completed all the
important points regarding a network
router now let's move on to the last
heading for this session that is
difference between a network curve
switch and a router
this difference we will use different
features to differentiate the working of
a hub switch and a router
the first difference is based upon the
osm model layer
in case of a hub it is active in the
physical layer of the osi model that is
also known as the first layer
and in case of a switch it is active in
the data link layer of the osm model
also known as the second layer
whereas a network router is active in
the network layer of the sm model also
known as the third layer
now let's move on to the next difference
that is based on addresses used by each
of them let's take a look
a hub as we already discussed doesn't
use a mac address or an ip address for
the transmission of data in the network
channel
in case of a switch it uses mac
addresses available in the network
channel to provide a guidance system for
the message to be transferred
whereas in case of a router it uses ip
addresses to transmit the data to the
designated device
let's move on to some other differences
that is
format of data used in each of them
hub uses electrical signals or bits for
data transmission in a network channel
whereas switch uses a data frame
or data package for the transmission of
data over the communication channel
and in case of a router it uses data
packets to be transferred
and the next difference is based on the
mode of transmission
let's take a look for this
a hub is based on half duplex network
connection that means
at a certain point of time only a single
device can share or receive data from
the other end point of the network
channel
and in case of a switch it is full
duplex network connection that means it
can simultaneously
receive and send a data packet or a data
frame to any of the network devices
connected in the system
similarly a router is also based upon
the full duplex network connection form
let's move on to the next difference
that is installation purpose
on the basis of installation purpose a
hub is mainly preferred in a lan network
or in a private network where two to
three devices are to be connected
which increases the efficiency due to
the absence of a processing unit in a
hub
as for a switch it connects multiple lan
networks or a large area network
available
as for the case in a network router it
is a global network that connects
multiple devices across the globe and is
also
designed to connect internet to any of
the device
let's take a look at the next difference
that is device classification
in case of a hub it uses broadcast
format or a broadcasting device to
transmit data over the communication
channel due to the absence of any
processing unit in the system
and in case of a switch it uses
multicasting application for the
transmission of data
and in case of a router it uses routing
path from a routing table to transmit
the data in the communication channel
let's take a look at a few more
differences
that is installation cost
a network hub can be installed very
easily in a network channel as it does
not perform any complex task
in case of a switch
it required moderate cost installation
as it performs some complex queries or
complex protocols in the network channel
whereas in case of a router it is the
most expensive to install in the network
channel due to the high device pics and
the performance based protocol
and the next difference is based upon
processing and intelligence
now that we are clear a hub device does
not have any
processing unit or intelligence point
and is the most basic point of data
transmission
whereas in case of a switch
it possesses
a processing unit
to differentiate the destination address
or a source address in the header format
of the message
whereas in case of a network router it
is a more sophisticated device among all
the three network devices as it performs
the most complex queries and
protocols in the network channel
what is network topology
it is referred to as an arrangement of
multiple systems and network devices
interconnected to each other
through a physical medium or logical
channel
the term network topology is combination
of two individual network concept
first is the network part
which represents the devices or systems
that are also known as nodes
which is connected and how to change the
data within the network
then the other part is topology which
represents the connection medium between
different network devices and governs
the data flow between them
moving on let's talk about why do we
apply the concept of network topology
for the first point it allows the users
to understand the overall model of the
network along with the number of devices
installed and their positions in the
network which provide ease of
installation of security measures and
network and helps in case of
troubleshooting cases
then for the next reason applying
network topology helps the user to
understand the communication
relationship among the different devices
and through a connection medium
this in turn helps the network
professionals to set up an optimal
network unit for the user
next in the list we have different types
of topologies used in networking
first is
the bus topology
then we have ring topology then star
topology then tree topology and in the
end mesh topology but to understand the
concept of topology let's start by point
to point topology this is simpler form
of topology connection which consists of
two nodes connected through a connection
medium like a network cable
the nodes at the two ends of the cable
shares data information between them
where the data sharing part represents
the network and the cable connection is
the topology part
with this we have understanding of
network topology then let's begin with
complex types of tech connections
first is the bus topology in this
topology the connection channel is a
single cable known as the network
backbone through which all the other
nodes are connected to
in this network setting the data packets
sent by the nodes are provided with the
receiver address to avoid transmission
errors
the data in this topology can travel
from any end point
where
they are termed as terminate points
advantages of bus topology it is easy to
set up due to the simple configuration
settings
this setting is also cost effective as
it requires only a network cable for the
connection
in the case of kreshnort the whole
network remains unaffected as it does
not have any direct connection to the
other node
let's take a look at disadvantages of
bus topology
in case of troubleshooting we require
the use of special equipment to detect
the fault in the network in the case of
multiple data transmission the packet
collision is the frequent occurrence
damaging the transmitted message data
due to the unavailability of network
devices such as switches repeaters etc
the loss of data over long distances
communication is quite high
then ring topology as the name suggests
the node in the network are connected in
a circular pattern similar to a ring
the data transmitted in this connection
is always in the clockwise direction
the topology does not have any
termination point due to its ring
structure the method of data
transmission is used is known as token
passing which involves sending a token
along with the data packet to which each
of the node matches to identify the
destination node using the destination
address in the token
next advantages of ring topology the
crash node can be easily removed from
the network
the configuration settings are not
complex for setup and materials are
easily accessible
the cost of installation is low as no
extra network device are required to the
connection
moving on we have disadvantages of ring
topology
in the case of a node crash the whole
system is affected and is non-accessible
due to the direct connection of each
node
the transfer of data is low due to the
token passing method in the network
difficulty in the troubleshooting fault
in the connection leads to the crash of
the whole network now let's talk about
star topology in this topology the
networks are connected to each other
through the central hub which can be a
computer or a server the central units
in the connection is also known as the
server and the nodes are known as the
clients any connection between the node
has to be through the server and is one
of the most popular topology connection
next advantages of star topology in case
of a node crash the network as a whole
remains unaffected as each node is
connected to the server of a connection
the hardware requirements are easily
available and of low cost
troubleshooting is easy
through the use of central hub to
identify the faulty node
disadvantages in case of a server
failure the whole network is shut down
as all nodes are interconnected through
the server
the connection configuration is complex
due to the pattern of the typology next
up free topology
this topology is a combination of tar
and bus topology the node connection in
the topology follows hierarchal pattern
with the topmost node as the root and
the branching node as the child node the
sharing of data is from the root node to
the child node pattern
next up advantages of tree installation
of a new network group is easy due to
the root child configuration of the
network
in case of a node fault or crash the
whole network is not affected by the
error this makes it easier to
troubleshoot the issue
next up disadvantages in case of a
server crash in any of the star
connection groups the whole network is
affected
due to the complex setting of the
topology installing security points is
difficult in the network configuring and
troubleshooting internal issues is quite
complex due to this topology next up
mesh topology
as the name suggests this topology is a
connection of interconnected system
connected to each other in no particular
order
no installation of network devices such
as switch or hubs this topology pattern
can be divided into two forms
first is full match topology in this
connection all the nodes are connected
to each other in the network then we
have partial mesh topology where all of
the nodes are connected to each other
available in the network let's talk
about the advantages of mesh topology in
case of node damage the whole network
does not suffer from the fault due to
the interconnected patterns of the
connection the transmission of data is
very high in the network
next up disadvantages
the cost of installation is high due to
the requirement of multiple cables and
nodes for the network to function
efficiently
the management of the network becomes
complex due to the large number of
interconnections in the network due to
the absence of repeater or a switch the
data signal loss during the transmission
is very high now let's take a look at
how to choose best topology for a
network configuration first of course
the installation cost is one of the
biggest factor that affects the type of
topology configuration we choose from
our network as the cost of installing
cables routers switches and other
network connections is slow then we have
easy installation installing the
hardware devices efficiently and
precisely is also one of the factors
that affect our choice of network
topology moving on we have flexibility
the ability of the topology to include
new network nodes after installation and
ease of troubleshooting refers to the
flexibility of topology in the hand we
have reliable security it is important
that the topology installed allows us to
introduce proper security points in the
network and leading the fewer crash
cases by referring the above factors we
can decide the best topology for our
network
firstly we'll understand what exactly is
the model
the tcp model is a method of sharing
data and information over the
communication channel
where the data has to go through each of
the four layer structure of the network
model
where it also performs tasks such as
remodeling of data efficient
transmission and air related issues
each layer has dedicated protocols that
they enact on the transmission data
now let's continue with the protocols
that are used in the tcpip model
to understand the protocols that are
used in the tcp model we'll compare it
with the osi model and if you want to
know more about the osi model you can
visit our video on the simply learn
channel
let's begin
the top most three layers of the osi
model which are application layer
presentation layer and session layer
collectively refers to the application
layer in the tcbip model
where they use
protocols such as ftp file transfer
protocol http hyper text transfer
protocol
telnet and smtp which is simple mail
transfer protocol
then we have the transport layer from
osm model which refers to the transport
layer in the tcp model
where they apply protocols such as tcp
transmission control protocol and udp
user datagram protocol
moving on we have network layer
from the osi model which refers to the
internet layer in the tcp model
which apply protocol such as ip internet
protocol icmp internet control message
protocol and arp
address resolution protocol
then we have data link layer and
physical layer from the usm model which
refer to the network access layer in the
tcp model
this layer doesn't exactly apply any
protocol but are connected to physical
medium which includes ethernet
wi-fi
and cables
now that we are completed with the
protocols regarding tcp model let's take
a look at the layers in detail
the tcp network model consists of
different layers where the original
model consists of
four different layers which are
application layer transport layer
internet layer and network access layer
then we have the updated model which
consists of layer
application layer transport layer
internet layer data link layer and
physical layer
let's take a look at the layers in
detail
the first layer that we are going to
know about is the application layer
application layer
this layer acts as an interface between
the application and programs that
require the tcp model for communication
including tasks performed by the layer
such as data representation for the
software application that are executed
by the user and then forwarded to the
transport layer
the protocol supplied by this layers are
http hypertrx transfer protocol which is
used to access information available on
the internet then we have smtp simple
mail transfer protocol which is used to
access email related tasks
moving forward we have the transport
layer
this layer is responsible for
establishing connection between the
sender and the receiver device
this layer performed the task of
dividing the data from the application
layer into packets
where they are used to create sequences
which are then transferred over to the
destination device it also performs the
task of maintaining the data that is to
be transmitted without error and
controls the data flow rate
the protocols that are applied in the
transport layer are
tcp transmission control protocol which
is responsible for transmission of
segments over the communication channel
then we have udp user datagram protocol
which is responsible for identifying
error in the data that is to be
transmitted over the communication
channel
moving forward the next layer is the
internet layer
this layer is responsible for the
transmission of data over the network
channel that is they provide a proper
route for the packets to be transferred
over the communication channel
the protocols that are applied by this
internet layer are
ip protocol which is the internet
protocol
this protocol assigns a unique address
to a physical system
so that it can be identified on the
internet
then we have arp
address resolution protocol
this protocol is used to find the
physical address of the system using the
internet protocol address
in the end we have the network access
layer this layer is a combination of
data link layer
and physical layer from the usm model
where it is responsible for maintaining
the task of sending and receiving data
in drawbits
the raw bits are transferred from the
center side to the receiver side in the
format of binary digit which are zeros
and ones
let's move on with the advantages of
using the tcpip model
the tcpip model assigns an ip address to
each of the system that is available on
the network channel so that they can be
identified on the internet
then they are also responsible for
enacting different protocols on the data
that is to be transmitted over the
communication channel the tcp model also
enables the user and the system to
access different format of data over the
communication channel
now let's take a look at the last topic
for this session which is the osm model
versus the tcp model
on comparing both of the network models
we get
the osm model consists of seven
different layers whereas the tcpip model
comprises of four different layers
the osi model has separate session layer
presentation layer whereas the tcp model
comprises of a single application layer
the transport layer in the osi model
provides packet delivery protocols
but in the tcp model
transport layer does not provide any
such protocols
the osm model is implemented during
network communication
but in case of tcp model it is used as a
reference model for the network channel
to better understand the osi model let's
take a look at a scenario
assuming we have two different systems
with different operating system
installed in them
and there is a communication channel
between them over which the data is
shared
but sometimes during transmission of
data
it faces some problems
these errors often arise due to the
different operating system installed in
the system or due to a network problem
during a transmission
but to overcome such situations
the osi model structure is used
using the osi model structure we can
make the transmission of data over the
communication channel error free
let's take a look at the definition for
the usm model
the osm model stands for open system
interconnection model
or a specifically designed set of
protocols and standards
that governs the modeling and conversion
of the data for proper transmission over
the network channels
the osm model is based on the layer
structure where it consists of seven
different layers where each layer has
different set of protocols that are to
be applied on the data during the
transmission
over the network channel
let's take a look at the different
layers of the usm model
the osm model consists of seven
different layers which perform specific
functions and apply different protocols
at different layers to maintain the
quality
and prevent the data from getting
corrupted when it is transmitted over
the communication channel
let's take a look at each of them the
first layer is known as the application
layer
which is a top most layer
then we have the presentation layer
session layer
transport layer
network layer
data link layer
and physical layer which is the last
layer of the usa model
the upper four layers in the isi model
represents the host layers
that is they interact with the
application related issues
when the data is transmitted over the
communication channel
whereas the lower layers are termed as
network layers
they specifically deal with the
transmission related steps for the data
over the network channel
let's take a look about some information
in regards to the layers
now let's take a look at the function
and the data format that is handled by
each of the layers during the
transmission of data
the first layer is the application layer
which interacts as a gateway for the
host datum and network applications
and handles the data format
then we have the presentation layer
which handles the initial step towards
the conversation of data for transfer it
also handles the data format
then we have the session layer
session layer establishes a connection
between the network devices for the data
transfer
then we have the transport layer which
oversees the data that is transferred
without any error and is in the same
pattern needed by the destination system
the data format handled by this layer is
segment format
next we have the network layer which
determines the part for the data
transfer it handles packet related data
then we have the data link layer which
performs the task of connecting the
physical nodes for the transfer of data
it handles frame data
and in the end we have the physical
layer
which is used to transfer the raw bits
that is in terms of ones and zeroes over
the physical mode
now that we are clear about different
layers that are present in the osm model
and some information regarding them
let's take a look at each of the layers
in detail
we'll start with top to bottom that is
the application layer will be the layer
that will be starting with
let's take a look
the topmost layer in the osm model is
the application layer which acts as an
interface between the user and the
applications that are being accessed
which can be
internet explorer chrome
or
any email client
it also handles different protocols that
are needed for the data transmission
over the network channel which can be
given as
hypertext transfer protocol the http
protocol and the smtp protocol which is
the simple mail transfer protocols
now let's move on to the next layer
the next layer is known as the
presentation layer
the presentation layer is responsible
for performing conversion tasks over the
data that is received from the
application layer
the conversion of data is done in
accordance to the required format
it also performs encryption over the
converted data so as to prevent it from
getting hacked by cyber criminals or
hackers
the compression of the encrypted data is
also performed by the presentation layer
so that it can be passed on to the
session layer
the next layer in the osi model is known
as the session layer
in this layer
the communication channel between two
different devices is established
the network devices are individually
known as
session the data that is transferred is
to be done over these session channels
the layer that is the session layer
establishes and terminates these
sessions in case of an error or some
other unforeseen event
this layer is also responsible for
authentication checks regarding the data
that is being transferred and also
provides data recovery options in case
an error occurs over the communication
channel it's a model list
let's take up a question
the question is what is the main action
that takes place at the presentation
layer
and the options are
first option data segmentation second
option encryption of data
third option framing of data
and the fourth option
bit conversion of data
you can provide your answers in the
comment section below
let's move on with the next layer
the next layer in the osm model is known
as the transport layer
the main task performed by this layer is
to break the data that is received from
the session layer into different
segments
these segments comprise of protocols
which are udp protocol and tcp protocol
along with the data that is segmented
from the received data
then the segmented data along with the
udp and tcp identification it
transferred over to the transmission
channel where then it's further
transferred to the network devices that
requested for the data
this layer also performs a very crucial
part which is the flow control
let's understand flow control over the
network channel through a small example
in this example the server has a
capacity to send 50 mbps of data at once
whereas the receiver side has a capacity
for 10 mbps
when the data is transferred from the
server to the client it transfers 50
mbps
but it isn't possible to transfer all
this data at once due to the lower
capacity on the client side
which is why the flow control changes is
required which is provided to the server
side by the transport layer
now let's move on to the network layer
which is the third layer from the bottom
in the osm model
this layer is responsible for breaking
down the segments into data packets
by adding ip address to them that is
received from the transport layer
these data packets are then further
transmitted over to the best possible
route to the destination system which
are governed by the internet protocols
including ip and ipv6 protocols
for example if we have a data that is to
be transferred to the network device 2
bit choose the best option
that is the root to be transferred over
to that network device
now let's move on to the next layer in
the osi model which is a data link layer
this layer is responsible for
maintaining and terminating the
established connection between the
devices over the network
the mac address in this layer is added
to the data packets
which are collectively known as data
frames
these data frames are then further
transmitted over to the physical network
these are divided into two different sub
layers
medium access control that is mac which
controls the established connection
device
and the second sub layer is logical link
control layer llc which identifies the
address and provide flow control for the
data
this data frame as earlier told is
transferred over to the physical layer
now let's take a look at another
question to brush up whatever we
learned so far
the question is
which layer includes the mac sub layer
in the osi model option 1
application layer option 2 session layer
option 3 data link layer option 4
transport layer
you can give your answers in the comment
section below
let's move on to the last layer in the
osm model which is a physical layer
this layer is responsible and provides
the physical medium over which the data
frame is transferred
but the transfer data is converted into
bits before it's transferred
the transmission of data is covered by
different protocols that are embedded in
the physical layer
the transmission of once and zero's
format data is done it also responsible
for maintaining the data quality by
applying different necessary protocols
and maintaining the bit rate throughout
the transfer of data whether it be
wired medium or wireless media let's
understand the dhcp protocol
the dynamic host protocol or dhcp
is a protocol that is designed to assign
the ip address to a device for it to
access the internet
this network model is based on the
client server architecture and removes
the process of manually assigning an ip
address to the system
now let's take a look at the allocation
methods for the dhcp protocol
the allocation method of dhcp is divided
into two types
the first type is the manual allocation
which as the name suggests is the
signing of ip address to the system
manually by the user
the second method is dynamic allocation
which uses a blind server architecture
to assign an ip address to the system
now let's see some points regarding the
allocation method
the first type is the manual location
as mentioned in this allocation type the
user manually assigns the ip address to
the system for accessing the internet
and can be observed in this instance
this is done by accessing the network
configuration setting
of the device and also requires other
related configuration
such as
subnet mask
preferred dns server and default gateway
let's now take a look at the dynamic
allocation
in this allocation method the client
device receives all the relevant network
configurations from the dhcp server and
the system gets configured to access the
internet the provided ip address is
given for a certain period which is also
termed as the lease
now that we somewhat understand what
exactly the dynamic allocation in dhcp
server is let's take a look at a small
example
open the start menu
and type command prompt
when the windows open up
type
ip
config
slash
all command
as we see by this command we can take a
look at the network settings for our
system
over here we can see the dhcp is enabled
that means the configuration that has
been used on the system refers to the
dhcp server
and on the bottom side we can take a
look at the different network settings
that are given along with the ip address
by the
dhcp server that is subnet mask
default gateway
and the dns server
now let's continue with the video
now let's take a look at some of the
notable dhcp settings
the first one is known as scope as the
name suggests a scope refers to a range
of addresses that are available to a
dhcp server for allocation of the client
device
next we have is lease this setting of
the dhcp server is designed to prevent
the holding of ip addresses by a single
device
this is done by assigning an expiration
date to the leased ip address so that
the dhcp server has some minimum
addresses left for the client device
and lastly we have address reservation
in this dhcp setting the client device
requests the server to assign the same
ip address to the device
each time the address allocation takes
place
this is done by identifying the mac
address of the client device
now let's take a look at the operation
model for dhcp protocol
the dhcp operations are performed on the
user datagram protocol in short udp
which is applied on two ports under udp
which are both 67 and 68.
the first phase is where the client
broadcast a dhcp server message over the
network to connect with the dhcp server
this message basically means that it
wants to connect to the internet through
the dhcp server
the second phase is when the dhcp server
receives the dhcp message
according to the message the dhcp server
reserves an ip address for the client
and network configuration information
including subnet mask default gateway
and preferred dns server
in the third phase the client responds
to the dhcp server's offer through a
dhcp request message requesting the
offered ip address and relevant network
configuration for the system
then in the last phase
the server acknowledges the request
broadcast from the client and sends the
dhcp packet to the dhcp client which is
comprised of network configuration for
the client device
what is network address translation
the motive behind implementing nat is to
allow several network devices to connect
to the internet by a single public
address
the night model is a method to conserve
ip addresses by using a unique address
to represent the whole private network
and the mentioned public ip address is a
globally recognized ip address to access
the
internet let's move on to some more
details regarding network address
translation
the task of nat process is to translate
a private ip address in a network
to a globally recognized public ip
address
and vice versa
that is the same process begins from
public ip address to a private ip
address
this task is performed by a router or a
nat firewall
let's move on
the flow of this process is something
similar
like the router configured
acts as an interface between the private
and network and the public network
that means the private network will
communicate with the router when it
wants to access an internet
same is the case for public addresses
too when the public address wants to
communicate with the private network
the router will convert it to a private
network id
and allow us to access the internet
the reason behind applying that process
is to conserve public ip addresses
to be more specific it's ipv4 addresses
and it also provides much better
security to the network
now let's move on to the next topic
nat addresses
there are different types of terms used
in that process
more specifically there are some
addresses information that are necessary
to understand the process which takes
place during network translation
we will discuss them one by one
let's take a look at the first address
before we begin let's take a look at the
example
this is a general or any simple form of
nat translation process we have a
private network
a private device a router a public
network
that we can access internet through
the first term that is used is known as
inside local address
this ip address represents the host of
the private network
and this cannot access the internet
directly
unless provided by an isp server
after we have the inside local address
through the private network we share it
with the crowder
when the router receives this private
network id it converts it to the public
network that is known as
inside global address
this ip address represents the whole
private network
for the outside network
and is used to access the internet for
the private network
now let's move on to the remaining ip
addresses for nat
according to this example now we are
returning from a public network to the
private network please keep that in mind
according to this
the address type next comes up with
outside global address
this ip address represents the outside
network address for the host before nat
process took place
then we have outside local address this
ip address represents the actual address
representing the host on the internet
after the net process takes place
now let's move on to the next setting in
the topic choose from over 300 in demand
skills and get access to 1 000 plus
hours of video content for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
signs of math
there are different types of nat
available on the internet or in the
network channel but we will discuss
three
generally used ones
where the first one is known as static
nat
according to static nat process
in the given private network
each device will have
a
particular or a single ip address
publicly
designed to them
that means if you have two devices in
your private network
you'll have two different types of
public ip addresses for each of those ip
addresses that is available in your
private network
due to this property of the static nad
process it is also known as one to one
net
and is mostly used for personal
addresses
for example please take a look at the
diagram below
if we have a single ip address
in a private network
we will have a single public ip address
for the same
again if we have another private ip
address in the private network we will
have
a public ip address for the same
this represents static network
let's move on to the next one
the next type of nat process
is known as dynamic net
for the dynamic nat process
private network addresses is translated
to public addresses from a pool of
public ip addresses available to the
communication channel
that is
something similar to this
according to the example if we have two
private addresses available in the
network then we have two poll of public
addresses too
out of which we can convert the private
address to a public address
and for example if we have a third
private address and only two possible
public addresses pool then the third
address is dropped
let's take a look
at the diagram for a clarification
this is the pool of public addresses
available for this
network out of which
we converted 192.168.32.10
to
213.18.123 to point 100.
now let's move on to the last type of
nut available
this nat is known as port address
translation
in port address translation of nat
the process takes place something
similar like this
all the available private ip addresses
in the private network are converted to
a single
available ip address publicly
recognized
that means if you have five private
networks in your available network you
will have a single public ip address
available to all of them
due to this nature of this process it is
also known as not overload
but
the catches
all the addresses in the private network
available will have different port
number assigned to differentiate between
them
for example
192.168.32.10
is translated to 213.18.123.100.11
where 101 represents the
port number
similarly for the second private network
we have 192.168.32.12
which translates to 213.18.123
point
that is similar with the earlier case
but the change comes over
0.102
that is the port number assigned to the
second private address
now let's take up a small quiz to
refresh all the topics that we did so
far
and the first question is
what does outside local address refer to
in nant
your options are
name of insight source address before
translation
name of destination was before
translation
name of inside host after translation
name of outside destination host after
translation
please read the options very carefully
to answer this
now let's move on to the next
question and the question is
pat address is also termed as
part refers to port address translation
option a static net
option one to one nat
option c not overload
and option d
not overlapping
you can give your answers in the comment
section
now let's move on to the last heading
for this session that is
advantages and disadvantages of applying
nat in a network channel
let's take a look at the first advantage
of using nut
nat provides privacy and security
measures to the private address as it
converts
a private address to a public address
through which we can prevent our id from
being hacked over the internet
let's move on to the next advantage
that process is applied to conserve
approved ip addresses over the network
channel as discussed earlier in the
previous slide
nat process helps to conserve us ipv4
addresses
now let's look into some disadvantages
of applying nat in the network channel
and the first disadvantage is
not translation leads to part delay and
prevent some applications
to lose their access over the network
channel
now let's take a look at the second
disadvantage
according to the nat process router is
the one that translates a private
address to a public address or vice
versa
during this process it does happen to
tamper with the port numbers as we
already discussed
but according to the rules set by the
network channel
router is not usually allowed to hamper
with the port numbers but it has to
because of nat introduction to distance
vector routing
distance vector routing refers to the
distance or the vector that is between
the neighboring nodes
in a network channel
and the routing part refers to the
established route through which data
packets are transmitted in the network
channel
the other aspect of this routing
protocol in a network channel is to
determine the shortest path for a data
packet in the network to reach its
destination
next we will look into some key points
regarding the routing protocol
for routing protocol
three primary key points are to be
remembered
first one being
each router in this protocol is designed
to share the vector data of each node
throughout the network
this step is done to maintain proper
circulation of data in the network
channel
the next key point is the routing
pattern in the network protocol
that is the data shared by the routers
is transmitted only to those nodes that
are directly linked to a particular
router
the last key point is
that the routing protocol is designed in
a manner that it shares the updated
vector data periodically
at the network channel
now let's move on to the next heading
that is
the algorithm used in the protocol
the algorithm used in this protocol is
termed as
bellman fold algorithm
this algorithm defines the shortest path
that the data packet can take to reach
its destination node from an initial
node
where
d of x y refers to the least distance
from a node x to node y
moving on we have
c of x comma v
where x is caused from each of its
neighboring v node is taken into
consideration
then we have
d of
v
this is the distance of each neighbor
from its initial node
and lastly
min of v
this is an abbreviation used to
determine the most shortest vector after
the solution is obtained using the
algorithm
in the next heading that is network
example we will understand all the
points used in the algorithm
now let's design a network model with
five different nodes
that are a b c and d
with each node connected to each other
using different network channel
the numerical values in the network
channel refers to the vector count that
is the distance from node a to node b or
to some other node in the network
channel
in a network model each node shares its
vector data with its neighboring node at
a regular interval
as there are various updates in the
network model
this data is shared in a form of routing
table where three different columns are
used
first being destination column
second
vector column that is the distance node
and lastly the hop
let's take a look at the neighboring
nodes for this model
for node a we have
b and e as it is directly interlinked to
the node a
for node b we have
node a and node c
for node c we have b and d
for d we have
c and e
and lastly for e we have node a and node
d
these nodes represents only the
neighboring nodes
now let's solve an actual example on
routing protocol to clear all our doubts
and understand the key points
the example we will be taking
to solve is
this network model
the initial step to start solving the
network model using the distance vector
routing protocol is to make routing
table for each of the nodes
let's make the routing table for node a
this is the routing table for node a
where we have
destination as a
that means destination is a from node a
that means the distance vector should be
0
then we have
destination as b
let's take a look
in this given example there is no given
connection between a and b
that means
this distance vector would be infinity
then we have destination as c
similarly as node b there is no direct
connection
between a and node c
that means this is also infinity
and same is the case with node d
and in the end we have
node e that is the only directly linked
node
to node a that means the distance given
is 5 so the network
vector is 5.
let's make an another dropping table for
node e
this is the routing table for node
let's take a look
in this routing table the first is
destination to node
a according to the network model given
distance is 5 so the vector value is 5
but the hop
to a
then we have
destination as node b
according to the model the distance
vector should be
4
then we have
destination as node c
as given there is no direct connection
between node e and node c
that determines the value would be
infinity
then we have
node d
which represents
direct connection with node e
and the value is 7
and lastly
e destination from initial point e would
be zero vector
now let's make another routing table
similarly for node c
now using the same steps you can make
the routing table for the remaining
nodes that is
node b and node d
now let's move on to the next step in
solving the routing issue
this step is known as update step
in this step we use the vector column
from each of the node to update the
vector column or the routing table for a
particular node
in this part we'll use
node is vector column to update the
routing table for node a
and the steps are using the algorithm
that is the bellman fold algorithm we
used earlier
as we already know
moving from a to destination node a is
always 0 so we won't be doing this step
let's move on to the next one that is
moving from node a to node b
that would be
would be a comma e as we are using
vector column of node e
plus
and the distance used to reach e from b
a comma e represents
5
and
e to b represents 4 according to the
network model so the value is 9.
similarly let's solve
for a to c
to a to c we have a comma e plus
destination required to move from e to c
according to the network model we have
node a is only directly linked with node
e
so the value would be 5
but there is no connection between node
e and node c so the value would be
infinity
moving on we have
a to d
in this case we have
a comma e
the value would be 5
plus e to d that is a direct connection
and the value would be 7 so the total
distance is 12
and the last one is
a to e
for this we have a comma e that is
directly the neighboring node
the value would be 5
so the new routing table for node a is
0 9 infinity 12 and 5.
similarly let's take another node for
this
for the next node we will take node c
and we will update the routing table of
node c
using its neighboring nodes that are
node b
and node d according to the network
model
now how to do this step
firstly it's c to destination a
in case of node b we have
c to a that would be
c comma b that is a direct connection
plus distance required from b to a
according to network model we have c
comma b as 6 plus b to a does not have
any connection that is infinity so the
value would be null
then we have node d in this case we have
c comma d that is a direct connection 3
plus d to a that is again infinity
as it is not linked directly to node a
moving on we have
destination as b
for node b we have direct connection so
c comma b value is 6
whereas for node b we have
c comma d that is distance 3 plus
d to b that is infinity as it is not
directly linked with the node b
so again the value is null
then we have
destination as c
so connection between c to c is zero
moving on we have destination at node d
that would be c to d
as c to d
as there is no direct connection between
node b and node d
so the value is infinity
whereas for c to d is a direct
connection for node d so the value would
be 3
now for the last node that is
node e
in case of node b we have
c comma b
plus
b to e
where the value for c to b node is 6 and
b to a is 4 so the sum is 10
and now in case of node d we have
3
plus 7 that would be distance from c to
d and then d to e
and the value would be again 10
so we can use any of the side to reach
the destination node e
by completing all the steps we have the
new table for node c
similarly we can find the routing table
for all the nodes present
now to look into some key points we
learned
for the initial step use only the node
distance of immediate neighbors
nodes without distance that is directly
linked to each other is always infinity
for the update step use the vector table
of the only neighboring node we have for
the initial node
and lastly to continue the update step
roughly n minus 1 iterations are used
where the value of n is equal to the
number of nodes
for example
the model we took has
5 nodes that means we have to do a loop
of four iterations
assuming that a person had to send a
letter to a relative's house but he
wasn't sure which house though
so how can this problem exactly be
solved well
this problem can be solved if we take a
look at the house number mentioned on
the mail
let's take a look at the house number
mentioned on the mail
on the mail it seems like the house
number is 2 that means the mail would go
to house number 2.
similarly we also have an identification
method on the internet that is known as
ip address which is used to identify
different mails and the owner of that
email address
firstly we'll understand what exactly is
an ip address
an ip address or internet protocol
address for an example
is a unique numerical identifier
assigned to every network device when it
connects to the internet
this address is assigned by the internet
service provider which acts as a way for
the system to access the internet
applications and a unique identity for
the device
moving forward we will understand what
exactly are ip functions
to begin with ife functions can be
divided into two types for the first
function we have
the internet service provider assigns an
ip address to the network device the
first function of the address is to
provide an identity to the host on the
internet whereas the second identity is
used as a location address for the host
on the internet
let's now take a look at different
versions of ip address
ip addresses can be divided into two
types where the first type is known as
ipv4 address
whereas the other address is known as
ipv6
let's take a look at both of them in
detail
for first one we have ipv4 address
this is the original version of an ip
address developed on 32-bit binary
format which contains
2 to the power 32 address
the address range from 0 to 255 in terms
of zeros and ones
with four octets each of them separated
by a period
the network device uses binary format
whereas the numerical format is used for
the host reference
the first part denotes the network part
in an ip address and the second part is
for the host part
now let's move on to the ipv6 address
type
with the rise in technology the ipv4
could not complete the requirements so
the need for ipv4 arrows based on 128
bit address size which is sufficient for
a long time which is approximately 320
undecillion
this type of ipv6 address is designed
for four hexadecimal digits and eight
sets with each block containing 16 bits
separated by a colon
now let's take a look at the ip classes
ip classes are designed for the purpose
of easy assignment of addresses to the
network
divided on the basis of class size we
have five classes depending upon the
requirement of the network class a were
designed to accommodate networks with a
large number of network host where the
first bit in the octet is always zero
with the large number ranging from 0 to
127
then we have class b
class b fulfill the requirements for
medium size network host where the first
two bits for the network id is 1 and 0
with the range from 128 to 191
then we have class c which can fulfill
the requirement for small size network
host where the first three bits for
network id is 1 1 and 0
ranging from 192 to 223
from this we get that class a b and c
are used for assigning addresses to the
host network
and then we have class d
which is used for multicasting which
means it is used to send a signal from
one host to multiple hosts
like using video streaming where the
first four bits for network id is
one one one and zero
with the range from 124 to 239
and lastly we have class e network id
for this range is reserved for research
purpose and not assigned to any network
with a range from 240 to
255. see different types of ip addresses
on the basis of accessibility we have
private ip addresses and public ip
addresses
for private ip addresses the devices are
assigned addresses in a network and each
system is provided with a unique ip
address
which they can communicate through
within the same network
and cannot access public network
and they do provide much more security
in regards to the public ip addresses
let's take a look at the public ip
address now
for public ip addresses isp in our
internet service provider assigns it to
the router which allows the user to
access the internet and also different
network application can be accessed
with security less in comparison to
private ip addresses
let's now see
the other two types of ip addresses
which are static and dynamic ib
addresses
static ip addresses is assigned manually
and is constant to the system whereas
dynamic ip address is assigned by the
internet service provider
for static ip addresses the importance
is much more whereas the address is used
for business and is not beneficial to
have different ip each time
in case of dynamic ip address the
assigned ip for network devices do not
need dedicated ip
due to being constant in nature static
ip address is preferred to be assigned
as official address for a business
whereas in case of dynamic ip address
due to assigning different each time
when it connects to the internet
address provides much better security
and often prevents hacking
now if we want to take a look at the ip
address for a system which is publicly
available we can do by the following
steps
access your internet browser
and type
ip
address
and over here we can take a look at the
public ip address for the system
and if we want to take a look
at the system ip address which is
dedicated to the device you can do the
following steps access command prompt
and write the command ipconfig and you
can take a look at the system ip address
ipv4 addresses
the first version of an ip address to be
developed was based on 32 bit binary
format that counts roughly around 2 to
the power 32 bits of total ip addresses
in ipv4 format
which was sufficient at the initial
phase of network requirement
but is somewhat lacking according to the
current advancement in the network
technology
the addresses in this ip ranges from 0
to 225 in terms of zeros and ones
with four octets where each of them is
separated by a period
this is an example for an ipv4 ip
address
where the first three parts represent
the network id
and the last part represents the host id
using the ipv4 address as i reference we
can identify ipv4 addresses from ipv6
addresses
now let's move on to the next topic that
is ip classes
ip classes are designed to allow easy
and efficient assignment of ip addresses
to a network
depending on class size we have five
different ip classes in a network that
are named as
a b c and d
for the first part we have class a
that accommodates network with a large
number of network host
where the first bit in the octet is
always 0 with number value ranging from
0 to 127.
then we have class b
which can fulfil the requirement for a
modded number of network host
the lead bit is 1 and 0
and network id ranges from 128 to 191
then we have class c which can allocate
an ip address for low number of network
host where the first three bits of the
network id is 1 1 and 0
ranging from 192 to 223
so the above three classes that is class
a b and c
we can easily identify and assign
addresses to a network host
moving on we have class d
where it is used
for multicasting
that means it is used to send multiple
signals at the same time from a single
host
for example using video streaming
where the lead bit is 1 1 1 and 0 with
network id ranges from 224 to 239
and then we have class e
where the ip bits for this is reserved
for research purpose only
where the ip addresses ranges from 240
to 255
moving on let's take a look at some of
the features for ipv4 version addresses
where the first is
the memory required for storing ipv4
version addresses in a system is very
low
then we have ipp4 version addresses
apply connectionless protocol for
sharing data
and providing the best effort in
delivery
moving on we have stacking option for
ipv4 addresses
that means
in ipv4 version it allows to create a
multiple network over a single host
which allows different hosts to connect
to it
moving on we have
ipv4 version addresses being the
earliest ip designed are applicable to
most of the network devices and system
for connecting to the internet so it is
supported by
many devices
then we have ipv6 addresses
let's take a look
with the increase in the need for an ip
address the ipv4 version addresses are
somewhat unreal to complete the
requirements of the network host
so the need for ipp4 version auros
which is based on 128 bit address size
which is sufficient for a very long time
that is approximately 320 undecillion ip
addresses in version 6.
this type of ipp version is designed of
4 hexadecimal digit and 8 sets with each
block containing 16 bits separated by a
colon
moving on let's take a look at some of
the features for ipv6 version addresses
where the first is
ipv version 6 addresses provides an
integrated security protocol for the
network that is internet protocol
security
ipsec
then we have it allows its application
to extend in various services according
to the need of the network
it also allows address configuration
through stateful that uses dhcp server
for network settings and stateless that
applies auto configuration settings
ipv6 addresses also allows some methods
to convert ipv4 addresses to ipv6
addresses
which is according to the requirement of
the host or the network
moving on let's take a look at the
differences between ipv4 version
addresses and ipv6 version addresses
this heading would allow us to choose a
best ip address that we can
decide for a network
let's take a look at the first
difference that is address and
performance
in accordance to the address size ibv4
version is composed of 32-bit address
length and is the fourth version of the
internet protocol
for ibv6 we have the address size is 128
bit long and is the latest version of
the internet protocol
the second difference is
on the basis of address field type
ipv6 addresses are based on numeric data
with four fields each separated by a
period
whereas for ipv6 addresses are based on
alphanumeric type data with eight fields
each separated by a colon
the next difference is based on address
configuration
in ipv4 version addresses a manual
setting for the network is required
along with the dhcp configuration
settings
whereas in case of ipv6 version
addresses the network setting is based
in accordance to the systems requirement
and it also supports auto configuration
setting for the system
moving on we have the number of
addresses in each ip
in case of ipv4 the total number of
addresses are nearly 4 billion addresses
whereas in case of ipv6 version we have
320 undecillion addresses
now let's take up a quiz to understand
what we did so far
and the question is
identify the correct form of ipv4
version address in the given options
and the options are
you can give your answers in the comment
section below
let's move on to the next difference
that is address security and functioning
ipb4 version addresses do not provide
any security function for the network
whereas in case of ipv6 addresses
integrated internet security protocol
that is ipsec is responsible for the
security of the network
the next difference is
encryption and authentication settings
ipv4 version does not provide any
encryption or authentication services
for the network
ipv6 addresses do provide
mandatory encryption and authentication
services for its addresses
moving on we have address routing and
performance
ipv4 version follows routing protocol
that has rip for network configuration
and is preferred over ipv6 version
and in case of ipv6
it does not follow any routing protocols
and it uses static routes for network
functioning
what are switching techniques
switching techniques are network
techniques responsible for overseeing
the transmission of data over different
communication channels
they are also responsible for choosing
the best route for data transfer
next we will look into why to apply
these switching techniques
using the switching techniques we can
choose the best and the most efficient
route for data transfer in the network
for example
if we want to send some data from node a
to node b we can do so by
moving from node a to a switch then node
d then to node b
but doesn't this seems like too long
this is where the switching techniques
plays its role using the switching
technique we can choose the smallest and
the most efficient way that is node
switch then to the node b
next we will look into different types
of switching techniques
switching techniques can be divided into
three primary types
the first is
circuit switching
that requires a predestined path for
data transmission
then we have message switching which
integrates the destination address with
the data for transmission
and in the end we have packet switching
that divides its message into smaller
units known as packets
packet switching can further be divided
into two different types that are
virtual switching and data ground
switching
now let's look into some details
regarding each of the types
on the first node we have circuit
switching
in circuit switching for data
transmission to occur a pre-established
path is required between the sender and
the receiver node
for example
assume that we call someone
then this request is sent over to the
network switches
and the route is to be established for
the signal to pass through
after that system assigns a route for
the signal to pass through then
the receiver receives the call from the
caller side
this is how it works
now let's look into some points to
remember about circuit switching
for circuit switching we require a
dedicated channel established between
the source and the destination node for
the network to pass through
the data transmission can take place
only after the path is established
and the last point to remember is
other than the sender and the
destination node no node can interfere
with the transmission of data to the
established route
let's look at some advantages and
disadvantages of applying circuit
switching in a network
for first one we have advantages
data transmission in circuit switching
is sure to be established due to the
predestined path
circuit switching is preferred for long
and continuous transmission of data due
to the pre-established path route
then let's look into some disadvantages
the time required to establish the
connection is quite long due to the time
required to establish a path
also due to the continuous transmission
of data in circuit switching
more bandwidth is required for
maintaining the connection
let's move on with message switching
in message switching no predestined path
is established between the sender and
the destination node in the message
this technique integrates the
destination address into the data
transmitted and shared over the network
let's look into the setup to better
understand the working of message
switching
for first step the center node
integrates the destination address into
the message
then the whole message is transmitted to
the switching node in the network where
it gets stored for the next transmission
and similarly like the second step this
transmission of data is done over
the whole network
and finally
through the destination address in the
data it reaches the receiver's node
this is how the message switching works
let's take a look at some points to
remember about message switching
in method switching no predestined path
is established
it uses dynamic routing as the message
is transmitted through the communication
channel in real time
the each node in network switching
stores the data
unless it is transferred over to the
next switch node
let's take a look at some advantages and
disadvantages of applying method
switching
to begin with let's take a look at the
advantages
the size of the data that can be
transmitted over method switching is
variable
in message switching the use of
bandwidth is done in an efficient manner
now let's look into some disadvantages
for message switching the nodes that are
known as the switch node is to be
provided with sufficient storage memory
there is a delay in reaching the
destination due to the message technique
that is the message has to stop at each
of the switch node before it is
transferred over to the destination node
now let's look into the last switching
technique that is packet switching
in packet switching the message is
broken into smaller data units known as
packets
these packets are appended with relevant
network details for the transmission
over the network
let's look into the working of packet
switching
we know that in packet switching the
data is broken into smaller units
packets
which each packet is given a sequence
number for identification
these packets are integrated with
required sender and receiver address and
switching method to choose the smallest
route to reach the destination node
these packets are then recombined at the
destination node in the correct sequence
order
now let's look into some points to
remember for packet switching
for packet switching all the data
packets that are provided with unique
number for identification at the
receiver end that is
one two three and four in the previous
example we just used
packet switching chooses the most
shortest path possible for the data to
reach the destination end
in case we have unreached packet or some
unattained packet the whole message from
the sender side is sent again
to the receiver end
now let's look into some details
regarding advantages and disadvantages
of applying packet switching
advantages of using packet switching is
it provides re-routing in case the
network node is busy
it also allows multiple user to access
the same network and no predestined path
is needed
the disadvantage of applying packet
switching is the protocols that are
needed for the working of packet
switching is very complex
there are often cases of loss of data
packets during the transmission in case
of overloading or corruption of data
the first heading is what is subnetting
the process of subnetting is to divide
the network into smaller network paths
this allows the system to have better
connectivity in the system
it also increases the security measures
for the network against hacking attempts
and also maintains an efficient flow of
network traffic
the smaller divided units of the network
are known as sub networks
taking an example of an ip address
with slash 24 representing the subnet
mask can be divided into two sub
networks of slash 25 subnet mask which
can further be divided into smaller sub
networks
now that we understand what is
subnetting
let's move on to class addresses and
subnet mask
firstly let's begin with class addresses
to better understand the submitting
process we need some information
regarding different classes used in ip
address
where the first class is class a
with the range of 0 to 127
network bits as slash 8
then we have class p with the range of
128 to 191
with network bits as 16
and lastly we have class c
with network range of 192 to 223
with network bits as 24.
the network bits representing each class
are very important when making subnets
of a particular ip address
let's see how they do so
for this we'll be representing each
class in binary format for class a we
have 1
for 8 bits
for class b 16 bits
and class c 24 bits
moving on we will see what exactly is
the subnet mask
to better define the sub networks in the
system we require the use of a subnet
mask
that is the subnet mask is a way to
differentiate between the portion of an
ip address that represents the network
address id and the host network id
in this
let's see the default subnet mask for
each of the class
for class a we have 255.0.0.0
for class b we have 255.255.0.0
whereas for class c we have 255.25
to better understand this let's take a
look at the classes individually
the network id part is the one that
represents the binary digit 1 whereas
host id represents binary digit 0.
that means for class a we have 8 bit
cells network id and the remaining bits
as host id
by looking at the host id we can see
that the network addresses that are
available for the host is the largest in
the class a
whereas for class pvm 16 bits for
network id and the remaining for host id
where we can see the remaining part for
the host id is lesser than class a that
means
class b can assign network ids for a
medium level company
and lastly for class c we have 24 bits
as network id and the remaining for host
id from this we can see that the host id
use for class c is the lowest that means
only smaller division companies can use
class c
moving on let's take a look at the
characteristics of the subnetting
process
first is the network id which represent
the first ip address in each subnet
block then we have broadcast id which
indicates the last ip address of the sub
network block
moving on we have first host id which is
the immediate first ip address after the
network id
then we have
last host id as the name suggests it
defines the ip address before the
broadcast id
continuing we have
next network id
this defines the network id of the next
subnet block
then we have the total number of ip
addresses
in the sub network block and lastly we
have subnet mask or cider which
represents the network id and the host
id part in an ip address
to better understand all the attributes
of the subnetting
let's take a look at an example
in this example we are assuming an ip
address 192.168.0
point x with a subnet mask of 24.
for this ip address we have divided it
into four parts that represent slash 25
slash 27 slash 27 and last part as slash
26
now let's find out the details that
means the attributes for the sub network
slash 25
the first attribute is the number of ip
addresses
going by the table we have 0 to 256
addresses in a single block
but in this slash 25 represent only 0 to
128
that means the total number of addresses
in slash 25 subnet block is
128.
moving on we'll find out subnet mask or
citer
that is the default subnet mask of class
c
which i have taken reference from the
subnet table which was explained in the
earlier slide
which is 255.255.
then we have the network id
which represents the topmost
network address in the subnetwork block
in our case it is 192.168.0.0
then we have broadcast id which is the
last ip address in any subnetwork block
in our case it is 192.168.0.1
moving on the network id and the
broadcast id addresses cannot be
assigned to any network device in the
network
because the network id is used to
identify the sub network block in a
network
along with broadcast id which is used to
communicate with any of the host that is
connected to the subnetwork block
that also means that the total number of
usable
network id addresses in a network block
is total number of ip addresses minus 2
that represents network id and broadcast
id
that would be
128 minus 2 and we get the value 126
which represents the total number of ip
addresses that are usable
moving on
the next attribute is first host id
that means the first id after the
network id which is 192.168.0.1
then we have the last host id
which is 192.168
which is just before the broadcast id
and lastly the next network id
which is 192.168.0
point
now that we are clear about all the
characteristics of our sub network how
about a practice round for everyone to
find all the characteristics for the sub
network block slash 27 subnet mask
you can give your answers in the comment
section
let's move on to the benefits of using
subnetting
where the first benefit is enhanced
network efficiency
through the use of applications of
submitting we can share data to not only
a specific portion of the network model
rather than broadcasting to the whole
network causing unnecessary traffic in
the channel as shown in the example
over here we see four different hosts
and if we want to share a specific data
put only two of the host we can subnet
them into specific parts
through this the router will only send
data to the specific portion of a sub
network rather than broadcasting to the
whole network channel this will prevent
network traffic
moving on the other benefit of using
subnetting process is
network security
separating also provides protection to
an extent against any hacking attempts
made on the network model
due to the complexity of the sub
networks as presented in the example
during the hacking attempt if we can
identify how the virus attacks the
network model we can prevent it from
attacking all the sub networks by
compromising a single or two of them and
preventing the remaining sub networks
let's move on to the drawbacks of using
subnetting process
the very first drawback of using the
subnetting process is it makes the
network model much more complex which in
turns affects the maintenance and
efficiency
then we have the unused ip addresses
which are left over
from applying the network model in a sub
network process
and lastly we have the low efficiency
use of hardware devices
if the hardware devices such as router
or switches used are of low efficiency
the performance of the sub network is
also decreased
the first is water network commands
the windows operating system provides
its user with numerous built-in network
troubleshooting commands these commands
allows its user to maintain the network
stability of the system
let's move on with network commands
now let's look into some of the most
important and mostly used network
commands in the windows prompt
the first one is ipconfig
this is one of the most basic network
commands used in the windows prompt it
gives an overview of the network
settings for our system
moving on we have ipconfig all
this is similar to ipconfig
but it gives a more detailed view of the
network settings for our system
then we have ping
this command is used to check or test
whether destination host is available
for exchange of services or information
moving on we have
tracearty this command provides the user
with an overview of the path that has
been taken by our ip address to reach
the destination ip host
then we have nslookup
this command is used when we have to
look into the server data of a
particular internet server for example
google.com
now let's look into some of the more
network commands
this we have
root
the root command provides the data of
routing data packets in the system over
the communication channel
netsat
it is used to get an overview of all the
currently connected networks from our
system
then we have arp the erp command is used
to display the arp cache in an organized
format
then we have pathping
using this command provides us with the
output combination that is of both trace
rt and ping to a certain extent
and in the end we have system info
this command provides us with the
comprehensive overview of the device
settings in a system
now let's look into the demo for the
network commands to better understand
them
to execute the network commands we have
to access the windows prompt
to do this
type cmd
and you will
access your command prompt
the first network command that we will
execute is ipconfig
the ipconfig command displays
network settings as an output
as we can see
this is the main connection that my
system currently have
with the ip address
192.168.1.3
along with every ip address a subnet
mask is included this is very important
as already told ipconfig just shows an
overview of the connection settings but
if you want to look into more detailed
version of the network settings for our
system
we use the command
ipconfig
all
as visible ipconfig oil command provides
us with a much more detailed view of our
connection settings
including dhcp settings
along with
the lease obtained for ip address
the default gateway
including the dhcp server settings
also
details about the dns server
now let's take a look at the next
network command in the list that is
nslooper
nslookup command is used to access the
ip address of a particular website or a
host through its domain name
this network command is helpful when we
don't know the ip address and wants to
know it
but we only have the domain name
let's take a look
let's clear the screen for much proper
view
ns look up
by default the nth lookup command
provides us
with the data of our system that is the
default server that my system is
currently connected to
and the ip address of my system
to access some other website or host's
ip address through its domain name you
have to write
ww dot
in this case let's take google
dot com
and press enter
through this from this part we can
access the ip address that has been used
by google.com
let's try using some other domain name
for example
www.amazon.com
as we can see
the ip address
the alias and the name from the
amazon.com
till this point we have seen what is
ipconfig command ipconfig all command
and the ns lookup
now let's move on to the next command
that is ping
ping command is used to check whether
our system
can access a particular website
let's take a look
to come out of the ns lookup command do
control c
now let's try
pink
to access the ping command we will use
the domain name
www.amazon.com
and press enter
after the execution of the ping command
we can see
that our system sent four packets
and
the destination ip also received four
packets that means the loss is zero
this means that the amazon website is
accessible from our system and there is
no loss of data in during the
transmission
in case if we don't have a domain name
for a particular website we can also use
the ip address for example
ping
and followed by the ip address
in this case let's take the amazon again
the ip address is
23.33.245.99
and press enter
as we can see the system has again sent
four packets to the destination ip
address and the destination has received
four packets without any loss
now let's move on to the next network
command in the list
that is tracearty the tracert command
is used to trace the path that has been
taken by our ip address to reach the
destination ip address
which is very helpful if we want to
troubleshoot the part that has been
taken
but before we use tracert we need a
destination source
let's try using
nslookup
and
use the facebook's ip address
let's exit the ns lookup command
using control c
and type
tracert along with the ip address of
facebook.com that is 157
dot
240
dot
228 dot
35
and press enter
on execution of the trace tracert
command we can see the number of routers
or network devices that our system's ip
address has to go through to access
facebook.com
and we can see the number of hops that
are available are 13.
let's see the number of hops our system
has to take to access facebook
and seems like the number of hops it
takes to access facebook from our system
is
it
through the use of tracert command we
can see
how many hops and what
devices or router our ip address has to
go to access a particular website
now let's move on to the next network
command
that is root command
root command is used to access and
manipulate the ip routing table of our
system
you can access this command using route
and print
and this
enter
as we can take a look
it provides us with the destination
ip address along with the net mask
gateway and interface
all these are necessary for a network
programmer to take a look of any details
that are regarded in the target or the
destination ip address host
with this let's move on to the next
network command that is
netstat
this network command is used to access
the connections that are currently
available on a computer system
through the tcp and udp ports
to display the result let's write
netstat and press enter
from this
we can take a look
the number of connections that are
currently available
or
inactive
or in case closed
to the netstat command
now let's move on to the next network
command that is
arp
let's clear our screen
and use arp
the arp network command is used to
access
the ip addresses for a device along with
their physical addresses
to use this we have to write arp
if you do this and press enter you'll
access the help mode for arp command
to access the output you have to write
arp hyphen a
in presenter
with this we can take a look at the ip
address along with the physical address
and also the type of ip addresses they
are for example the first one is
a dynamic ip address whereas the rest of
them
are static
now let's move on to the next network
command in the list
that is the path ping command this
network command
is used
to access the path that our ip address
take for the destination host along with
the calculation of loss of the data that
has been transmitted over the
communication channel
to do this
type pathping
along with the destination source that
is for example
facebook.com
and press enter
on doing this
we get the number of routers and the
path that has been taken
by our ip address
to the destination host
partnering command might take some time
to execute
after the execution of the command this
is the whole result that we receive on
our window
these eight represents the path
and the static stick represent the loss
at each point of ip address during its
transmission over the channel
now let's take a look at the last
network command in a list that is system
info
at the name suggest system info is used
to access or display
the whole overview of a system devices
setting
to do this write
system info
and press enter
as we can see all the data regarding
my system device is
displayed
as an output
what is user datagram protocol
the user datagram protocol commonly
known as udp protocol is designed to be
unreliable and connectionless in nature
which applies process to process
communication model for data exchange
between devices and is active in the
transport layer of the osi model
and is used to transfer
data and information related to internet
services over the network channel where
process to process communication refers
to the use of port numbers in the header
format during the transmission of data
over the network channel
as for connectionless
it means that
the utp format does not provide
established path for the data to
transfer instead it uses multiple
different paths which we will look into
further in the video
let's move on to the next heading
features of using user datagram protocol
the user datagram protocol provides the
network with various efficient and easy
to understand network protocol features
to apply over the data that is to be
transmitted
where the first feature of udp is
related to the working area that is the
udp model is a transport layer protocol
of the usm model and is used to deliver
best effort delivery options for the
data transmission where the best
delivery option refers that the protocol
does not provide the sender
will receive any acknowledgement from
the receiver side for the data
transmitted
or it does not provide any guarantee of
data transmitted to the receiver site
now let's move on to the second feature
of user datagram protocol
the second feature represents the mode
of delivery a connection that the udp
establishes for data transmission
the udp protocol as we know already
establishes
a connectionless path that means there's
no actual virtual path for the data to
be transmitted
so that the each data from the udp
format uses a random path available in
the network channel and reaches its
destination
now let's move on to the next heading
that is udp header format
the udp header format comprises of two
parts
first the udp header part which is eight
bytes in size and second the data to be
transmitted
furthermore the header part is divided
into four different parts
source port destination port total
length and checksum
where each of the parts are divided into
16 bits
let's take a look at the different parts
of the header format in a little detail
the first one is source port number
it is a 16-bit value that is used to
identify the port that is transmitting
the data
next is destination port number
that is used to identify the port number
that will be receiving the data on the
receiver end
next we have total length as the name
suggests this value is used to specify
the total length of the udp packet
including the udp header part
and the last is checksum this is a 16
bit value field and is used as an
optional attribute
it is left empty if there is no need
or it is used in case where accuracy of
the data is to be measured
now let's move on to the working of the
udp protocol
begin with we have data from the sender
site
which is enclosed with the udp header
for communication and data in the udp
header part
the next step is to hand over this data
over to the ip section
for encapsulation
with the ip header and data with the udp
header and data part
as for the last step
this part is handed over to the frame
section where it is transformed with the
frame header and data format
moving on now let's transmit the data
over the network channel for the
receiver and to receive it
over to the receiver side first step is
decoding of frame header part and data
part into the ip section which contains
ip header and data section
again this ips packet is divided into
udp header part and data part
from where the message is retrieved from
the data section of the utp header
format and is then received by the
receiver end
now let's move on to the applications of
udp protocol
let's take a look at some of the
features of the udp protocol that
provides applications to various network
models
for the first one we have it provides
flow control and error control mechanism
to the network model such as tftp
next it provides faster transmission of
data as there is no pre-established
virtual path needed
so it is used for real-time services
live communication
and gaming services
now let's move on to the last heading
for this session that is udp versus tcp
protocol
we will differentiate between udp and
tcp based on some attributes that are
mostly used in the network model
and the first attribute is reliability
for udp protocol as we already know now
it is an unreliable in nature
that is it does not provide any
guarantee of data transmitted to the
destination side is reached or not
as for tcp
it provides reliable and guaranteed data
delivery to the receiver side
the next attribute is acknowledgement
signal
the udp protocol does not provide any
acknowledgement from the receiver side
to the sender side
whereas in case of tcp protocol sharing
the acknowledgement signal is very
important
if the acknowledgement signal is not
shared by the receiver side to the
center side the data exchange will halt
let's move on to the next attribute that
is connection mode
as we already know now udp is a
connectionless mode of service there is
no virtual path established for the data
transmission to takes place
whereas for tcp protocol it is a
connection oriented protocol
that is a virtual path is needed for the
data to be transmitted over to the
receiver side or the destination node
the next attribute is error check system
in udp protocol basic check system is
only used for error check
whereas for tcp protocol it is an
extensive error check service
and along with error flow control
mechanism included in the tcp protocol
service introduction to the protocol
the stop and rate protocol is a type of
flow control mechanism active in the osi
model of the data link layer
the transmission of data applies only to
the noiseless
channels where a noiseless channel
represents an ideal network channel
where no frames are lost duplicated or
hacked
moving on we have
the stop and rate protocol is
unidirectional in transmission of data
that is
either sending or receiving data will
only takes place at an instance
for the third point we have
the stop and date protocol as the name
suggests is when the sender shares a
data packet to the receiver end
then the sender side has to stop and
wait for the receiver side to send an
acknowledgement before it starts sending
the next data packet
with this point we are now knowledgeable
about the working of the stop and
protocol at an elementary level
now let's move on to the next heading
the next heading for the session is
steps involved in the stop and wait
protocol
the steps for this protocol are divided
into two parts sender and receiver
protocol
let's start with the sender side
the first step is to transmit one data
unit at a time to the receiver end by
the sender side
and the next step is
to transmit the next data until only
after we receive the acknowledgement
from the receiver end
now let's move on to the receiver side
in receiver side step one is to receive
the data and use the data that is being
sent
then the second step is after the data
has been used by the receiver side it
will send the acknowledgement to the
sender side for further data
transmission
this is how the transmission of data
takes place in the data protocol
now let's move on to the next heading
that is working of stop-and-wait
protocol
using the previous two headings we can
easily determine the steps involved in
this working
let's take a look
to begin with we have two sides the
sender and the receiver side
the first step is
to send the data from the sender side to
the receiver in
and after the receiver side has used the
data it will send the acknowledgement
signal
meanwhile the sender side has to wait
for the acknowledgement signal
only after it receives the
acknowledgement signal will it send the
next data packet
now that the sender side has sent the
data for the second time the receiver
site will use this data and then only
share the acknowledgement signal
this process of sending data from the
sender side to the receiver side and
receiving acknowledgement from the
receiver side to the sender side
continues
for n number of times
according to the given scenario in the
network channel
now let's move on to the next heading
that is also the last heading for this
session that is drawbacks of using
stop and read protocol
the first drawback of using this
protocol is the loss of data
this issue can arise when transmitting
data from the sender side to the
receiver end
it may be due to any issue
due to hacking attempt or network
disruption
or any other network related issue
then
this can also arise when receiving
acknowledgement from the receiver site
now let's move on to the second drawback
the next issue is related to
acknowledgement transmission that is
during the transmission of
acknowledgement signal due to the
network issues
the acknowledgement signal is disrupted
and the transmission is terminated
this can arise again due to any reasons
that are occurring in the network
channel
now let's move on to the last drawback
for this heading
the last issue occurs due to the delay
in transmission time of the information
time delay drawback can occur on either
side of the transmission that is during
data transmission
or the acknowledgement transmission what
is a protocol
as we know in a networking concept
protocols refers to the rules and
instructions
that governs the data transmission
between different network models and
devices in a communication channel
the data transmitted using protocols is
easily handled and is reliable to use
as well as it provides a secure channel
for the data to be transmitted
now let's move on to the different types
of protocols available in a network
channel
the protocols available in a network
channel can be divided into two
different types
noiseless channels and noisy channels
where the noise part refers to any
external interference data error or
duplicate transmission in the network
channel
furthermore noiseless channels and noisy
channels can be divided into
subdivisions let's take a look at the
noiseless channels first
noiseless channels can be divided into
two types
simplest type and stop in weight type
whereas noisy channels are divided into
three subdivisions
stop and wait arq
go back
and arq
selective repeat arq
in the noisy channel go back in ar q and
selective repeat ar q are the ones that
apply the sliding window protocol for
data transmission over the network
channel
now let's look into some information
regarding sliding window protocol
to begin with the sliding window
protocol is a technique that allows the
share of multiple data frames in a
network channel
where the number of frames shared is
determined by the window size assigned
to the network channel
also the frames sent during transmission
are assigned with a sequence number for
efficient frame transmission in the
communication channel
till this point in the video we have
already learned about the definition of
what is the sliding window protocol
now let's look into the working steps of
the sliding window protocol
to begin with we have a standard site
and a receiver site in the network
channel
then we require the frames where each
frame is given a sequence number for
this example we are using 0 to 8
which means a total of 9 frames are
available at the sender side
then using the window size we determine
the number of frames that can be shared
at an instance for example we'll be
using 3 as a window size for this
example
let's start with sending the first frame
that is 0
to the
receiver side
after the frame is sent a sliding window
appears on the number of frames
now let's move on to the next
that is frame one
the point to be noted is
before receiving any acknowledgement we
have to send all the frames that are
available according to the window size
that is for this example the window size
is three that means we have to send
three frames before we receive any
acknowledgement from the receiver side
let's send the last frame that is frame
2
now we have to wait for the receiver
side to send the acknowledgement signal
to the sender site before we can send
the next frame now that we have shared
the maximum number of frames the
receiver end will share the
acknowledgement signal for frame 0 with
the sender side
after this acknowledgement is received
by the sender side we can share the next
frame in the list that is frame 3
after the frame 3 has been sent
see the positioning of the sliding
window
the sliding window now changes from 0 1
2 to 1 to 1 3 frame
this positioning of the sliding window
represents that 0th frame has already
been acknowledged by the receiver side
whereas the 3rd frame is sent for
acknowledgement from the receiver side
by the sender side
and similarly we have to do the same
pattern for the next two frames that is
frame number one and frame number two
now the center side will receive the
acknowledgement for
frame 1 from the receiver side
and we can send frame 4 from the sender
side to the receiver side
now see the movement of the sliding
window
the sliding window changes from
one to one three frame number to two
three and four
similarly we can move on to the last
frame
now let's draw some simple conclusion
from all the working steps we have seen
so far
to begin with
frame number 1 and 0 represents the
acknowledged frames
whereas the frames within the sliding
window represents
the frames that are waiting
acknowledgement
whereas the remaining frames 5 6 7 and 8
are not yet shared with the receiver
site
now let's move on to the next heading
for the session
difference between stop and wait
protocol and sliding window protocol
the first comparison is on the basis of
working mechanism
where the stop and beat protocol is
designed to send the data frame at a
single time
and wait for the receiver to send the
acknowledgement to share the next frame
as for the sliding window protocol
sender can send multiple frames
simultaneously and then wait for the
corresponding acknowledgement from the
receiver end
let's move on
to the next comparison that is based on
the window size
on the basis of window size the stop and
rate protocol is always fixed at 1.
as for sliding window protocol as we saw
in earlier slides it varies according to
the scenario in the network channel
let's take a look at some other
comparisons too
the next comparison is based on
efficiency and time delay
as comparison on this basis the stop and
blade protocol is efficiently low and
suffers from more time delay
as for sliding window protocol the
efficiency is higher than the stop and
weight protocol which provides lower
time delay during data transmission
let's move on to the last comparison
sorting and transmission of data
for stop and wait protocol sorting is
not required
and it applies half duplex system for
data transmission
as for sliding window protocol we
require sorting for better efficiency
and is full duplex in nature
let's begin with the sliding window
protocol
sliding window protocol is a method to
share multiple data frames at a time in
a network channel
the frames shared in the network are
based on the window size assigned
beforehand in the network model
as for the last point we have
each of the frames are assigned a
sequence number for frame transmission
and also to achieve more efficiency in
the network channel
now let's look into some information
about the go back narq protocol
this protocol applies the sliding window
method for transmission of data in the
network channel where n in the protocol
refers to the window size assigned in
the network model
as for the term arq in the protocol
refers to the automatic repeat request
which means the sender side will send
multiple data frames to the receiver
side according to the assigned window
size
and only after it receives an
acknowledgement from the receiver site
will it continue to send the frames from
the sender side
moving on let's look into some important
points regarding the protocol
as to begin with the method applied to
share multiple frames from the sender
side to the receiver side is known as
the protocol pipelining
where each frame is assigned a sequence
number for proper transmission of data
in the network channel
now let's move on to some other
important points
as we already know
the n in the protocol refers to the
window size that is the maximum limit of
frames that can be transmitted from the
sender to the receiver side before
reaching the acknowledgement
for the previous frame
and in case if the transmission of the
acknowledgement of a frame is not
received within a certain time period
then all the frames from that sequence
number are to be retransmitted in the
channel
this point is to be remembered properly
because this will be the key point in
solving a question related to go back in
arq protocol
now let's move on to the working of the
protocol
to begin with we have a sender side and
a receiver side
along with the sequence number
the window size for the network channel
and the number of frames will already be
assigned in the network
now by applying the sliding window
protocol we will send the first three
frames from the sequence continuously
which will be frame number zero
frame number one and two
this is assigned according to the window
size
after sending the frames we will have a
sliding window over the sequence numbers
that are 0 1 and 2.
after the frames are sent to the
receiver side it will use the frames and
send an acknowledgement signal to the
sender side
that would be 0 for the first time
after which we can share the next frame
that will be frame number 3
from the sender side to the receiver
side
after sending frame three
the sliding window from sequence number
zero one to two will shift over to one
two and three
and similarly
for frame number one we will receive the
acknowledgement signal from the receiver
side to the sender side
and then we can share the next frame
that is frame number four from the
sender side to the receiver side
the sliding window will shift over from
sequence number one two and three to
over
two three and four
as for the next frame that is frame
number two when we receive the
acknowledgement from the
receiver side there is a catch
for any network issues
the acknowledgement is not received by
the sender side
so in this case as discussed earlier in
one of the important points the center
side will not transmit
frame number
five
instead it will re-transmit frame number
two three and four
where the second frame is the one which
did not receive the acknowledgement and
all the frames sent after second frame
is to be retransmitted along with it
that is three and four
to much better understand the solution
for the example we'll be solving later
in the video it is suggested that you
watch the steps involved in the working
of the go back and airq protocol again
now moving forward let's take a look at
some of the advantages and disadvantages
of using the protocol in a network
channel
for advantages we have it increases the
efficiency of transmission of frames
it also allows multiple frames to be
sent at once
and the time delay is low for sharing
the packets
as for disadvantages we have
the tree transmission of frames in case
of an error in the network channel is a
very difficult work
and it also requires
the storing of frames on the receiver
side that it receives from the center
side
now that we have learned everything
about the go back and air q protocol
let's take a look at the much awaited
working example for the same
let's take a look at the problem
statement
in a given network the number of frames
provided is 10
with the window size assigned as three
and for every fourth packet is lost
find the total number of messages or
frames sent from the sender side to the
receiver site
from this question
we can get
three main parts that are the number of
frames that are given is 10
as for the window size is three and
every fourth packet is lost
let's take a look at the options
option a27 option b25
option 22 and option d29
i'll give you guys a moment to take a
look at the question again
now let's move on to the solution
as usual we have the sender side and a
receiver side
and according to the question we have 10
frames
numbering the frames sequentially we
have frame 1 to frame 10
and then according to the question we
have window size as three
now using the sliding window method
we'll send the first three frames that
is frame number one
two and three from the sender side to
the receiver side
that will be
like this
after sending the frames we'll wait for
the
receiver side to send the
acknowledgement
and the sliding window will appear on
frame number 1 2 and 3.
now the receiver side will send the
acknowledgement for frame 1 to the
sender side
and using this we can send frame number
4 from the sender side to the receiver
and
side
sliding window appear on 2 3 and 4
sequence number
and similarly for frame number 2 we'll
send the acknowledgement from receiver
side to the sender side
and send frame number five from sender
to the receiver side
and a sliding window appears on sequence
number three four and five
then again for frame number three we'll
send the acknowledgement from the
receiver side to the sender side
and send frame number six from the
sender to the receiver side
and the sliding window appear on frame
number four five and six now let's move
on for the next frame for
acknowledgement that is frame number
four
for this frame according to the given
question every fourth frame is lost
during transmission from the center side
to the receiver side
that means
no acknowledgement will be sent from the
receiver side to the sender side for
frame number four
in that regards or any other frame that
are sent after frame number four that is
frame number five and frame number six
similarly frame number five and frame
number six will also get discarded
now let's re-transmit according to the
go back narq
protocol frame number four
frame number five
and frame number six
after re-transmission frame number four
will get acknowledged by the receiver
side to the sender side
that means we can send next frame that
is frame number seven from the sequence
order
and the sliding window appears on frame
number five six and seven
similarly let's move on to frame number
five
but before we do that let's count the
position of fifth frame in the
transmission order
one
two
three
four
5
6
7 and 8.
that's correct
when we count the position number for
any of the frames from the beginning we
use sequence
not the sequence number given by the
question
that means
fifth
frame is at the position number eight
from the beginning that means according
to the question it will get lost during
the transmission from sender to the
receiver side
similarly
frame number six and frame number seven
that was sent after fifth frame will
also get discarded
according to the go back in rq protocol
again we will retransmit 5 6 and 7 frame
number to receive a site from the sender
side
after re-transmission frame number 5
will get acknowledged by the receiver
side and then we can share frame number
8 from the sender to the receiver side
and the positioning of the sliding
window shift from 5 6 7 frame to 6 7 and
8 sequence number
now let's move on to the sixth frame
but according to the positioning order
position of the sixth transmitted frame
is number twelve
that means
it will get lost during transmission
from sender to the receiver side
and similarly frame number 7 and 8 will
also get discarded by the receiver side
and again applying go back in our queue
protocol we will retransmit frame
numbers six seven and eight
on re-transmission frame number six will
get acknowledged by the receiver side
and we can share frame number nine from
the sender to the receiver side
and the sliding window will shift from
sequence number six seven eight to seven
eight and nine
now let's recount the position of the
next frame that is frame number seven
from the beginning
and that would be
16 that means
frame number seven will get lost during
transmission from the sender to the
receiver side
and similarly frame number seven
eight and nine is to be retransmitted
according to the go back narq protocol
now similarly following all the previous
steps we can complete this network model
using go back in our queue protocol but
this is a work you guys have to complete
and find out the total number of packets
that were transmitted from the sender to
the receiver side
and give your answers in the comment
section
let's start off with question 1 what is
the osi model explain the different
layers of the osi model osi largely is a
theoretical model
utilized to understand networking and
how data packets are created and how
they are being processed by a computer
this is normally used by the tcp the
transmission control protocol over
internet protocol
software suite
so osi is known as the open systems
interconnection model it is a reference
model that describes how applications
are going to interact via the computer
network
there are seven different layers that we
need to understand they are as follows
so in this diagram there are these seven
different layers we start up from the
bottom first is the physical layer the
data link layer network layer transport
layer session layer presentation and
application
when such a question is asked in an
interview it is not only that we
identified these seven layers explaining
what the osi model is in the first place
we then try to identify these seven
layers and we give a brief description
about each and every layer if there are
any additional questions they will come
after
this basic question
so let's start off with the physical
layer
this is the lowest layer of the osi
model now this is where any and every
physicality of your computer comes into
the picture so it could be a
network interface card it could be an
rj45 or a cat5 cable anything that
allows data to be transmitted physically
from your machine to another machine
next comes the data link layer
so on the data link layer as far as
networking is concerned we just need to
understand that data packet is encoded
decoded into bits at this layer this is
also the layer that deals with mac
addressing so the physical address of
every network network interface card
which is the mac address which is
utilized to
route
data packets over the network this is
where the mac address resides on the
data link layer
the next layer is the network layer
here datagrams are transferred from one
to another the function of this layer
are routing and logical addressing the
moment we talk about routing and logical
addressing ip addresses come into the
picture ip version 4 ip version 6.
so network layer will deal with ip
addressing and the routing of those
packets
then comes the transport layer this is
the layer responsible for end-to-end
connections that automatically signifies
that this is where tcp and udp will be
working
tcp stands for transmission control
protocol udp for user datagram protocol
tcp
is a connection oriented protocol
whereas udp is a connectionless protocol
these two protocols are utilized to
establish connectivity between two
machines
tcp is a more reliable method of
connectivity because there are a lot of
packets that are sent across to verify
that the data has been sent data has
been received and so on so forth whereas
udp is a connection less protocol where
data is just dumped without verifying
whether the receiver
actually receives that data or not
so in a nutshell on the transport layer
tcp and udp make their appearance and
this is where that functionality lies
then comes the session there
this controls signals between the
computer it establish maintains and
terminates connections between processes
so in the transport layer we talked
about tcp and udp udp being a connection
less protocol where data is just
transmitted without verifying whether
the receiver received that data or not
whereas tcp we studied is more of a
reliable protocol thus
there are different packets signals that
will be sent across to verify that data
has been transmitted it has been
received properly
and then the next uh segment of that
data is being sent so those control
signals are established using the
session layer so the three-way handshake
of tcp the acknowledgement packets and
uh
those kind of packets will be taken
taken care of on the session layer of
the osi model
then comes the presentation layer
the presentation layer is responsible to
translate data into the application
layer format so the formatting right
mime or encoding that is being utilized
the utf-8 character set that we utilize
for
presentation encryption mechanisms all
of these work on the presentation layer
and finally comes the application layer
where
the application itself uses a particular
protocol
so that the
other
machine on the receiving end
the application on that machine will be
able to understand what the
communication was about
right so in a nutshell
if if i start from up top the
application layer will deal with any of
the data that the application
uh is generating so maybe an user input
you're logging in you're typing the
username password all that data will be
constructed let's say into an http or
https format that's where application
layer comes into picture then the
formatting of which into utf-8
and the encryption of which would be
done at the presentation layer
then this transport layer and the
session layer would kick in to establish
a tcp session do the three-way handshake
establish that connectivity ip
addressing would be done on the network
layer mac addressing would be done on
the data link layer and when everything
is ready on the physical layer the
packet will be sent out at the receiving
end the packet will be received on the
physical layer and then all these layers
will be reversed and finally at the
application layer the data would be
presented to the application who would
then execute it and showcase it on the
screen
of the recipient
so this is the way you want to explain
this question you want to be very
concise precise about what you're
explaining you don't want to go into two
hypothetical scenarios you don't want to
delete earlier with the layers you just
want to give the basic functionality
want to demonstrate that you understand
what the osi layer is how the computer
functions and you want to move on from
there if the interviewer has any further
follow-up questions they will ask those
specific questions
so that's question one moving on to the
question two
question two is define unicasting
multicasting and broadcasting
now this is a question which can be very
lengthy but again most of your interview
questions
are designed that way it's basically to
understand how much conceptually you are
aware about these technologies so you
have to be very concise don't go
rattling about technology too much
but in a concise manner just try to
explain what these things is so when
data is being transmitted over a network
it can be transmitted either in one of
these particular manners it can either
be a unicast multicast or a broadcast so
what is unicost
unicast is when a message is sent from a
single user to a single receiver so one
to one right so
uh one machine talking to another
machine and nobody else so also known as
point-to-point communications one point
to one of the point if you have to send
information to multiple receivers then
you will have to send it using multicast
right so this is where
your multicast networking comes into
picture so in our case uh let's assume
it's a network where there are
there's a class c network approximately
255 odd machines
and within these there are two machines
that want to talk to each other
if they want to talk between each other
it would be a point-to-point
communication where they will utilize
unicast where only these two machines
will have visibility of that
conversation and the other machines will
not even realize that this conversation
is taking place
if
one machine wants to talk to multiple
machines
then the multicast comes into the
picture as the name suggests in this
mode of communication data is sent from
one or more or more
sources to multiple destinations
multicast uses the internet group
management protocol also known as the
igmp protocol to identify groups so
under this igmp protocol various groups
are created where machines
are subscribed to those particular
groups and whenever a message needs to
be sent through those groups
it will be identified by the igmp
protocol and then that particular
message will be sent to those multiple
machines that are members of those
particular groups
and then comes the broadcast
the third method is known as the
broadcast as it says it is going to
broadcast to all so this is one to all
that is communication between a single
user and it is going to be sent to all
the machines in that particular network
right so the three ways unicast is one
two one
multicast is one to many
and broadcast is one to all then
question number three
what is dns
dns stands for domain name system it is
like the internet's phone book that is
responsible for mapping the domain name
into its corresponding ip address and
let me give you an example over here
whenever we go and open up let's say a
browser a google chrome browser we type
in www.google.com
and then we press enter and magically
google comes in front of us the website
rather
now how does the computer know who
google is because as far as we are
concerned humans understand google and
words like that computers don't
computers
deal with binary zeros and ones
right and as far as internet is
concerned they will only deal with ip
addresses and mac addresses so how does
a computer know how to find google.com
and where is it located so the moment we
type in
in the browser window in the address bar
google.com and press enter a dns query
is generated automatically by the
browser where a packet is sent to our
dns servers asking what the ip address
is so in short dns resolves domain names
to their corresponding ip addresses
there is a dns server which will have
this index
a database of all the domains associated
with their ip addresses
if one particular dns server does not
have that information that you're
looking for it may query another dns
server who may have that particular
response
so the first thing is when you type in
domain name
it gets resolved with the dns it
identifies the ip address corresponding
to that particular domain name and thus
allows the computer to route that packet
to the particular
server where that domain name resides so
in this scenario if you look at the
screen on the local pc you have typed in
cybersecurity.com
there is a dns resolution that a query
that goes to the dns server what is the
ip of cybersecurity.com the dns server
looks it up in its particular database
if it has the corresponding ip address
it will then respond back the ip
addresses 172.17.252.1
after which the packet is sent off to
cybersecurity.com moving on to question
number four what is a firewall
now this is a very good question and
normally a very basic answer that i've
ever heard is that a firewall is a
hardware and a software firewall but
that's the functionality of a firewall
that is what how you can install a
firewall but there are different types
of firewalls and there is a specific
functionality that the firewall is
created for
right so firewall
is either a hardware or software
but its responsibility is for blocking
either incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer they
secure a network so essentially the
firewall will allow a connection to
happen or disallow a connection to
happen it won't go beyond that that's
the basic functionality of a firewall
okay so based on the
configurations that you have done based
on the rules that you have created on
the firewall it will then based on those
rules identify whether some traffic is
allowed in that network or some traffic
is
to be blocked from entering that network
so as the screen shows
the firewall rules will analyze whether
the traffic is good
if yes it will allow if the traffic is
bad it will block the traffic and not
allow that connection from happening in
the first place
now there are few common types of
firewalls that also need to be included
in the answer to this question and the
first one is a packet filtering firewall
these are the most common types that you
will come across which analyze packets
and lets them pass through only if they
match an established security rule set
now here people do get confused when we
say that we analyze packets
people think that these firewalls will
analyze the contents of that packet
which is not correct
when the definition for a packet
filtering firewall says that these
firewalls analyze packets it means that
they are only analyzing the source and
destination ip addresses port numbers
and the protocols that are mentioned in
those packets
these firewalls do not have the
capability of deep packet inspection or
a dpi as it is known if that capability
comes into the picture you are basically
looking at an intrusion detection system
or intrusion prevention system in
today's world called as a next gen
firewall
okay so a packet filtering firewall
essentially will only analyze data
packets for its source and destination
ip addresses port numbers and the
protocol that is being utilized it will
then map that information to the rules
that are there on the firewall and based
on those rules it will either allow that
a connection to happen or disallow that
connection from happening
the second type of is a proxy firewall
these firewalls filter network traffic
at the application level so when you say
application level they work at the layer
7 of the osi model packet filtering
firewalls since we have mentioned that
they've worked on ip addressing and port
numbers will work on
the network layer of the osi model also
on the transport layer because you also
look at protocols
proxy firewalls will work at layer 7
which is the
application layer of the osi model and
will deal with application level
protocols such as http https ftp smtp
and so on so forth
and the third one is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall these
filter packets are the network transport
and application layers so they basically
do
the job of the first and the second type
of firewalls
the packets are compared to known
trusted packets but now the first
question is if there is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall why do
we have type 1 and type 2 firewalls like
packet filtering and proxy firewalls
that is because that is how the
firewalls have evolved we started off
with the packet filtering then we added
functionality to it and so on so forth
so if a question comes what is a
firewall you start off with the option
saying it is a hardware or software this
is the responsibility the functionality
of a firewall
is to allow good traffic and disallow
bad traffic based on the rules that have
been configured on the firewall and then
you've got basically three types of
firewalls packet filtering proxy and
stateful multi-layer and just include a
brief description of each of these
firewalls if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
then moving on to question number five
what is a vpn
vpn is also called a virtual private
network it is a connection between a vpn
server and a vpn client
so it basically creates an encrypted
term between the client and the vpn
server which is then utilized to
secure the connections that you're
making with the internet so as you can
see in the diagram the user has a vpn
client installed on the machine the vpn
client then creates an encrypted tunnel
to the vpn server
and through this tunnel encrypted data
is transmitted which can then be
processed by the vpn server
uh sent to the internet information can
receive can be received back by the vpn
server the vpn server will encrypt that
data back and send it back to the user
so if there is a man in the middle
attack that is happening or a hacker
trying to eavesdrop on the
communication mechanism they will not be
able to do so because of the encrypted
technique it is very difficult to
decrypt this or hack through this
encrypted tunnel
it is possible but it is very difficult
to achieve that moving on to question
number six what are the advantages of
distributed processing
now before we go into advantages of
distributed processing we first have to
understand what is distributed
processing
so it is a term which describes various
computer systems
that use more than one processor to run
an application
here multiple computers across different
locations
share the same processor the advantages
of distributing processes are as follows
but before we go into the advantages
distributed computing is basically where
multiple machines will pull their
resources together
to run a singular application so an
application that has multiple resources
and can scale up and scale down as and
when required
the advantages are that it can be very
very useful in data recovery
for example raid
where you're striping data on various
hard disks it is reliable it is cheaper
lower cost can be achieved and it is
easy to expand because of the
scalability factor that we just talked
about if there is loss of data in one
computer it can then be recovered by
another interconnected computer and one
of the examples would be blockchain in
today's world right what is blockchain
that this data is
uh created live and stored on a
connection of computers so if one of the
computers goes offline the other
computers in that network will still
have that data
and the blockchain will still function
without any issues the second point a
glitch in one machine does not affect
the processing as there will be multiple
other machines like we discussed in the
blockchain
several cost effective mini computers
are used instead of costly or mainframe
machines so instead of having a server
bank
i can have multiple machines connect
interconnected together
and they can function
in that particular blockchain or for
that particular distributed processing
mechanism
depending on the amount of data
processing more computers can be
attached to the network thus you can
increase the number of computers that
can be a part of that blockchain or you
can reduce them as and when necessary
moving on to question number seven what
is tcpip
tcpip or transmission control protocol
over internet protocol
is a set of communication protocols that
are used to interconnect networking
devices on the internet this protocol
defines how data should be transmitted
over the internet by providing
end-to-end communications so essentially
if you want networking to be established
on your machine you will need tcp ip
without tcp iep there will be no work
groups there will be no domains
basically your interconnectivity will go
for a task
tcp is a software that once installed on
your machine will then interact with the
hardware which is your network interface
cards and then your switches wires
cables and all those through protocols
that have been already pre-configured in
it
so within the tcp iep suite of softwares
you will have all the protocols all the
functionality of the osi layer
and each and every protocol that works
on each and every layer will be
predefined and pre-configured to work in
a particular manner the internet
protocol is all about routing each
individual packet to make sure it
reaches its destination so with the tcp
you're talking about the protocols that
will allow you to format the data and
generate it so that you can communicate
it over the network the ip will then
deal with the routing of those packets
so that the packet can be routed to the
correct computer and be received by the
recipient
so the tcpip model is the compressed
version of the osi the seven layers will
get converted into four layers the
network access layer internet layer
transport layer and application layer
going on to question 8
what do you mean by ipconfig and
ifconfig both of these are commands the
first one on a windows machine the
second one on a linux machine
so ipconfig is known as the internet
protocol configuration this is a command
that is used on the command line
interface of microsoft windows to view
all the adapters and the configuration
of each and every adapters for their
network interfaces so as you can see on
the right hand side in the command
prompt screen if once you type in the ip
config command on the c prompt and press
enter it will give you a list of all the
adapters that are there
so you can see wireless lan adapter
local area connection the media is
disconnected it doesn't exist at the
bottom you will see the wi-fi connection
wireless lan adapter and can give you
the ip version 6 ip address ipv version
4 address the subnet mask and the
default gateway so this is the
configuration that allows the machine to
know on what network it is on what is
the default gateway for communicating to
the internet what is the subnet mask so
how many computers may exist in that
particular network and what is the ip
address of that specific computer so
that it can communicate across the
network as well ifconfig is the same
thing on the linux mac or unix operating
system
so
the command will also give you the list
of interfaces and the configuration of
each and every interface
it is used to configure control the tcp
network interface parameters from the
command line interface
it allows you to see the ip address of
these network interfaces so here you can
see
the
wlp19s
the ipr is being 192.168.43.215.
subnet mask being 255.255.25.0
with the broadcast being 192.168.43.255.
nine
what is the difference between a domain
and a work group this can be a very
interesting question and can be a very
lengthy question at the same time a work
group is nothing but a decentralized
network where you have
interconnected multiple machines
together and each machine acts in its
own individual capacity
thinks of itself as a server right
so a decentralized network use every
user manages the resources individually
on their pc so local users on their own
pcs
managing
the network shares what can be shared
from that particular machine what data
should be shared should not be shared to
whom it can be shared with and so on so
forth
it is good if you've got a small network
uh a few machines all together uh and
you want them to interact with minimal
management effort
right so each computer each user will
decide what they want to allow other
users to see on that particular network
and all of them would be connected over
a lan a local area network either a
wireless or a wired one so if you look
at your home wi-fi right now that is one
of the best examples of having a work
group
the domain on the other hand is a
centralized network model so in a
corporate environment whenever you go
there and you got a domain based
username and password which
when entered onto a particular machine
gives you access to the entire network
or whatever applications and whatever
resources have been allocated to you
that is where the domain comes in so it
also uses a single sign on mechanism for
all the resources that are made that are
to be made available to you whereas in a
work group your local user only meant
for that particular computer right so
coming back to the domain it is an
administrator who is going to manage the
entire domain and all of the resources
connected to the domain the resources
could be switches routers servers data
stores applications web servers mail
exchange servers and so on so forth so
all of these are administered by an
administrator through the domain
it is the most reliable and optimum
solution for a large network where
multiple users are going to interconnect
and share that data amongst each other
right the computer can be connected to
any network that means you can be on the
internet and through the internet using
a vpn you can connect to your corporate
network authenticate in and get access
to whatever resources you are allowed to
access whereas in a work group you have
to be a part of that network to access
that particular network if you change
your location you go and connect to
another wi-fi you will lose access to
your previous wi-fi then the last
question for the networking uh section
what is data encapsulation in networking
data encapsulation refers to the process
of adding headers and trailers to the
data
the data link layer binds each packet
into a frame that contains the hardware
address of the source and the
destination computer so in this example
when you're talking about data
encapsulation we have talked about how
data that has been created by the
application layer would have a header
and a trailer that will give
the various informations of where that
data needs to be sent so the hardware
address which is the mac address comes
into the picture and gets added to the
header and the
ip addresses port numbers and all of
those things would then be added to this
uh traders as well so that the data can
be then routed to the intended recipient
of that particular communication with
this we are completed with this full
course on computer networks
if you have any questions regarding the
topic you can ask them in the comment
section
thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you